hey I'm Milo vintamilia I'm here with
BuzzFeed to take the which iconic Milo
ventimilia character are you quiz
here we go first
what's a quality you look for in a best
friend loyalty honesty courage kindness
hard-working good sense of humor I'm
gonna go honesty your friends got to
tell you the honest truth like whether
you want to hear it or not right pick
something to order at a diner pancakes
cheeseburger and fries milkshake
omelette coffee grilled cheese grilled
cheese all the way sandwiches one
thousand percent which character would
you trust with a secret Rocky Balboa
from Rocky Rebecca Pearson from This Is
Us Luke Danes from Gilmore Girls Susie
Meyerson from The Marvelous Miss maisel
Randall Pearson from Mrs us Claire
Bennett from Heroes I'm gonna go Mandy
Moore Rebecca Pearson all the way uh
what type of movie would you love to
star in rom-com a horror a superhero a
period piece a western or sci-fi sci-fi
by million although a western would be
fun take a while grow a nice handlebar
mustache wear a cowboy cap now choose
one of these movies from the 80s to
watch tonight
it's gonna be all of them When Harry Met
Sally The Outsiders Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom Breakfast Club risky
business or The Princess Bride
between Risky Business The Princess
Bride I'm gonna go to Princess Bride
pick a song you can listen to 100 times
without getting sick of it cuff it by
Beyonce All Too Well by Taylor Swift
Bohemian Rhapsody by Queen Here Comes
the Sun by The Beatles as it was by
Harry Styles and Dancing Queen by ABBA
I'm gonna say Bohemian Rhapsody because
honestly I think I haven't heard a lot
of these other ones finally choose a
photo Milo took and post it to Instagram
so it's either a Sunset Beach photo me
with the real life Matterhorn the uh the
famous short shorts that were normal
length but I pulled them up over my legs
shorts me and my camper me and an orange
that's been peeled or a rock by the sea
with a hole in it this is hard they're
all made
um
I'm going to go
with
oh boy oh boy this is hard
I'm not going to tell you what I went
with I got Jack Pearson This Is Us I got
Jack
that's me with a beard Jack Pearson your
personality matches Jack you're
optimistic loyal and caring like Jack
you're fundamentally good person who is
always trying their hardest to make the
people around you feel safe and welcome
but wait there's more you're someone who
has overcome some obstacles in your life
to get where you are today your family
and friends are the most important
people in the world to you
I think I'm more like Jack than anything
I'm not sure how many other characters
I've played that are on here you guys
can find them all but I feel probably
closest in line to Jack in a lot of
different ways
oh man you got Peter Petrelli in here
you're someone who's very sensitive
Peter was very sensitive he was really
really sensitive
Charlie Company keep Charming ambitious
and hard working oh wow you got Rocky
Balboa Jr in here Robert other iconic
model of intimate characters are
handsome man from The Marvelous Miss
Mason we actually I know he's handsome
man on here but you learn his name
in the final season of Miss maisel so
stay tuned
again I might have been familiar guys
watch The Company You Keep on ABC Sunday
nights at 10 9 Central and you can also
see it on Hulu just fine thank you
BuzzFeed it's good seeing you guys
appreciate you
[Music]